this is an interesting story that did
not get a lot of attention since it came
out right around new year's day but i do
think it's worth uh covering
joe biden is going to have a completely
new secret service team in his immediate
presidential protection team
and you might be saying well what's the
big deal uh new president new protection
team right well the big deal is that
um some reassignments are common when
there's a presidential transition
some agents move into being the people
right around the president
some move out of it joe biden is going
to be getting an entirely new team
though
because there are concerns about having
donald trump's sycophants
around joe biden secret service
is often considered a political simply
simply there to provide
security there are reportedly trump
sycophants that are now part of the
presidential protection team
individuals who for example were
discouraging each other from wearing
masks to be politically in line with
trump on covid
even though officially the federal
government was saying all of our
employees are going to be wearing masks
the secret service allowed former
security detail leader anthony ornato
to temporarily leave his role and serve
as white house deputy chief of staff
very unusual very unorthodox decision
and that same guy ornato
is the one who coordinated that insane
stunt
where trump held a bible in front of a
dc church
after the clearing of peaceful
protesters from the area
he planned some campaign rallies and the
like so bottom line
they are going to be replacing the
entire presidential protection team and
to be frank i think this makes sense
it's terrible that this is necessary it
appears to be necessary secret service
agents are around the president during
extremely
sensitive events and meetings and the
idea that
some trump anti-massacres or loyalists
of any kind
would be around biden is horrifying and
the plan is to bring back
some senior agents that knew joe biden
from his days
as vice president and combined them with
some
newer agents i actually never thought
that much
about the politics of secret service
agents
but then this guy dan bongino came along
and bongino was a secret service agent
who worked on protective duty
for george w bush and then he stayed on
with barack obama
and then we found out bongino is a
completely out of his mind
right wing nut that would actually scare
me as someone
protecting a president particularly a
democratic president
he's now part owner of the right-wing
social media network parlor
he said uh that during trump's
presidency his life has become about
owning the libs that's a quote he
supported the spygate conspiracy theory
from donald trump and on and on
and on and my suspicion is that this is
actually going to be a bigger problem
than merely the secret service obviously
secret service is of
particular importance because we're
talking about keeping the president safe
but my suspicion is that there have been
trump loyalists installed
at medium to lower levels in many
agencies
and often when you have a presidential
administration that changes
the leadership at many of those federal
government agencies also changes you
know
the directors and deputies to those
directors maybe a little bit lower than
that
in order for everybody to sort of be in
line with the with the incoming
president but
because of how trump and his cronies
operate i would
guess that there are tons of loyalists
and cronies
below the level that a white house would
be involved in hiring for
and that is a a real concern and we'll
have to see
how that manifests during the first year
or two of joe biden's presidency you may
well have as a result of donald trump's
incredibly cronyistic handling of every
aspect of government
entire departments filled at the low to
mid level
with trump sycophants and loyalists so
my
guess would be that over the first 18 to
24 months of joe biden's presidency
we'll be hearing about these rogue acts
of defiance from low-level folks like as
an exam i'm not
predicting exactly this but as an
example uh
biden directs nasa to once again start
studying climate change
and some lower level folks refuse to put
the information back up on the website
maybe it's a bad example because nasa
actually does seem to be um
uh focused on doing good science but
that type of thing and it'll have to be
rooted out it'll sort of be equivalent
to
when the supreme court uh legalized gay
marriage nationally
you had that deranged wacky kentucky
county clerk kim davis
who just resisted uh issuing marriage
licenses in her county
obviously it failed she was just
replaced but she was temporarily held up
as a martyr
by some on the right it's going to be a
very interesting couple of years